[Music]
foreign
and here are three reasons why you
should take the what they forgot to
teach you about our project oriented
workflows with Git and GitHub Workshop
number one I'm really excited to co-lead
this workshop with David for the second
year in a row David is a Solutions
engineer at posit and I'm a lead data
scientist with the prostate cancer
clinical trials Consortium
David and I work really well together
and we learn from each other our diverse
perspectives really benefit the
participants in this course
number two
the spirit of the what they forgot to
teach you about our Workshop are
strategies to improve the quality of
your our life via project workflows and
Version Control with Git and GitHub
these are paradigms that you can benefit
from no matter what stage you are in in
your career
number three lastly the what they forgot
to teach you about our content is solid
this Workshop has actually been
instructed since 2018. so the course
content has a really strong Foundation
that's assessed every year to be updated
for new developments so I really hope
you can join us
hi I'm David Audra I'm a Solutions
engineer at posit sometimes I describe
that as a role focused on helping data
scientists get their ideas into
production but in practice what that
means is that a lot of the time I'm
focused on the parts of working with r
that aren't about writing our code but
more about what it looks like to manage
it to share it and help it answer
questions for lots of different user
groups and so the reason I think you
should take what they forgot to teach
you about are because I think it helps
as an opportunity to help you learn some
of the software engineering fundamentals
that
aren't really going to come up in other
kinds of our focused programming classes
I know that when I started learning our
programming I was very much focused on
like how do I extract the data from this
HTML table and not as focused on
questions like what is it going to look
like to work on this project again in
another year or what's it going to look
like to collaborate with this project
with silence and I think that what they
forgot is excellent venue for learning
that kind of thing so I hope to see you
there
thank you